Hello everybody, my
name is Dr. Eugene
Petkoe and today I
will present the first
part on the pathology
of bone and joints.
We will cover quite
a few entities
which I have enumerated
on this slide.
We will start with
osteoarthritis,
then we will discuss
rheumatoid arthritis,
acrondoplasia,
osteoplasia, osteogenesis
imperfecta, osteoporosis
and osteopetrosis,
ostomalacia and
rickets, pages
disease and
osteonecrosis.
Osteoarthritis or
degenerative joint
disease. This is
characterized by cartilage
degeneration resulting
in structural and
functional failure
of synovial joints.
It is the most
common type of joint
disease, usually starts
without any apparent
initiating cause. It's
an aging phenomenon,
in which case we
call the condition
idiopathic or primary
osteoarthritis.
It affects a few joints,
it's oligoarticular,
but in some cases
might be generalized.
In about 5% of
cases we see
osteoarthritis
in younger people
with predisposing
conditions.
This is the so-called
secondary osteoarthritis.
Overall the knees
and hands are
more commonly
affected in women
and hips are
affected in men.
There is a strong
association with aging.
The prevalence of
osteoarthritis increases
exponentially beyond
50 years of age.
Now let's talk a
little bit about
pathogenesis of
degenerative joint disease.
Ultimately in
degenerative joint disease
we have degeneration
of articular
cartilage as well
as a disorder repair
and the biomechanical
stress is the most
important pathogenic
mechanism. However,
genetic factors
including polymorphism in
genes encoding components
of matrix and signaling
molecules might
predispose to chondrocyte
injury that causes
matrix alteration.
So the chondrocytes
are very
important in
this setting.
The chondrocytes
proliferate and
continuously synthesize
proteoglycans,
but disease develops when
degradation exceeds
synthesis of
proteoglycans
by chondrocytes.
However,
chondrocytes will
also secrete matrix
metalloproteases,
MMPs, which degrade
type 2 collagen
network in cartilage.
The action of MMPs
is counteracted by
a tissue inhibitor
of metalloproteinase,
which is secreted
locally and we know
that in osteoarthritis
there is an
imbalance between MMPs
and tissue inhibitor
of metalloproteinases.
In addition,
there are numerous
cytokines and
diffusible factors
released from
chondrocytes and
synovial cells,
especially TGF
-beta which induces
production of
MMPs, TNF, tumor
necrosis factor,
prostaglandins,
and nitric oxide,
which are also
implicated in
osteoarthritis.
In addition,
a chronic low level
inflammation would
contribute to
disease progression.
In advanced disease,
there is massive
and severe loss of
chondrocytes, and
there is significant
matrix dextraction.
Osteoarthritis stages.
In early stages,
the chondrocytes
proliferate and
form clusters.
Concurrently, matrix
water content increases,
proteoglycan
concentration decreases,
and horizontally
arranged collagen type
2 fibers are cleaved.
All of this would
result in fissures
and clefts creating
granular and soft
articular surface.
As chondrocytes die,
full thickness portion
of cartilage is
sloughed into joint
forming loose bodies.
Exposed subchondral
bone becomes
new articular
surface, polished by
friction with
opposing surface.
This results in the
appearance of polished
ivory or so-called
bone abernation.
Underlying articular
bone subsequently
undergoes
sclerosis, develops
small fractures
and creates gaps.
At this level
synovial fluid is then
forced into subchondral
regions and forms
loculated fluid
collection, which increase
in size, forming
fibrous walled cysts.
Then we see the appearance
of mushroom-shaped
bony outgrowths or
osteophytes which
develop at margins of
articular surface capped
by fibrocartilage and
hyaline cartilage which
gradually would
ossify However, the
synovium is usually only
mildly congested and
fibrotic and contains
few inflammatory cells
From a histopathological
perspective,
osteoarthritis
is characterized
by several findings.
First of all,
the tidemark separating
the subchondral
cortical bone from the
actual cartilage is
duplicated. Then
we see a herpetrophy
of chondrocytes,
they proliferate,
and on the surface
we see surface fibrillation
with fissuring.
Osteoarthritis is an
asymmetrical condition
which involves weight
-bearing joints.
Usually only one or few
joints are involved,
especially at the
level of hips, knees,
lower lumbar and
cervical vertebrae,
as well as
proximal and distal
interphalangeal
joints of fingers,
first carpometacarpal
joints and
first tarsometatarsal
joints.
What do we see at
the joint level?
We can see
osteophytes or bone
spurs, which are
palpated as nodes
Joint mice,
which represent
dislodged cartilage
and subchondral
bone in the actual joint
There is joint space
narrowing, which may be
seen radiologically and
subchondral sclerosis
which morphologically
is translated by
aburnation or an ivory
-like polished surface.
If you would aspirate
such joint you will
see that the level of
white blast cell count
is less than 2000
which indicates a non
-systemic process. I
would like to stress that
there are two types
of nodes that you can
palpate in osteoarthritis,
distal interphalangeal
nodes or Heberdine
nodes and proximal
interphalangeal nodes
or Bouchard nodes.
This is a chronic
autoimmune inflammatory
systemic disorder
which mostly attacks
joints producing
a non-superrative,
proliferative and
inflammatory synovitis.
Inflammation induces
proliferation
of granulation tissue,
which is called
tannus, which
erodes articular
cartilage and bone
Often progresses
to articular
cartilage destruction,
in some cases we
see ankylosis,
which is joint fusion
There are also extra
-articular lesions,
which may involve
the skin, the
heart, blood vessels
and lung, leading
to clinical
manifestations overlapping
with other
autoimmune diseases
Prevalence in the US
is approximately 1%
and the incidence
peaks between
the 2nd to the
4th decades and it
is 3 times more
common in women
Rheumatoid arthritis
pathogenesis.
The autoimmune response
characteristic for
this condition is
initiated by CD4 helper
T cells, possibly
by reacting with an
arthritogenic agent,
microbial or self-antigen.
And we know that
there is a genetic
predisposition but also
environmental factors
may contribute to
the development,
progression and
persistence of disease.
Pathologic changes in
rheumatoid arthritis
are mediated by
antibodies against cell
antigens and
inflammation induced by
cytokines mostly
secreted by CD4 T cells.
Activated CD4 T cells
release a variety of
inflammatory mediators,
cytokines, which
in turn will stimulate
other inflammatory
cells leading ultimately
to tissue injury.
For example,
interferon gamma is
secreted by Th1 cells
and activates macrophages
and synovial cells.
Interleukin-17 is
secreted by Th17 cells.
This will recruit
neutrophils
and monocytes.
Rank lichen is
expressed on activated
T cells and stimulates
bone resorption.
TNF and IL-1 are
secreted by macrophages
and stimulate synovial
cells to secrete
proteases that destroy
hyaline cartilage.
The most important
factor seems to be
TNF, which is most
firmly implicated
in rheumatoid
arthritis pathogenesis.
We have at the
present time anti
-TNF biologics
which are used
for therapy in
this condition.
If examined
histologically,
synovium displays
numerous germinal
centers with secondary
follicles and
abundant plasma
cells, Some secrete
antibodies that
recognize self-antigens.
Many of these
autoantibodies,
also produced in
lymphoid organs,
are specific for
citrullinated peptides.
Anticitrullinated
peptide antibodies
are diagnostic
markers and are
detected in serum
of up to 70%
of rheumatoid
arthritis patients.
IgM and IgA
autoantibodies that
bind to IgG FC
regions present
in 80% of these patients.
This is known as
rheumatoid factor and might
be seen in joints as
immune complexes not
present in all patients
but can be found in
patients with rheumatoid
arthritis as well.
Anticyclic
citrullinated peptide
antibody is more
specific than rheumatoid
factor for
rheumatoid arthritis.
About 50% of risk
of developing
rheumatoid arthritis
relates to an inherited
genetic
susceptibility, HLA-DR4
-allel, associated with
anti-citrullinated
peptide-positive
rheumatoid In
rheumatoid arthritis,
we have two major
events, failure of
tolerance and
unregulated lymphocytes
activation on one
side, and enzymatic
modification, for
example, citrullination
of cell protein
on the other side.
The immunological
pathway is determined
by susceptibility
genes, HLA and
others, and the
enzymatic modification
such as citrullination
of cell protein is
determined by
environmental factors,
various types of
infections, smoking,
and others.
These two type of
events would lead
to activation of T
and B cells which
respond to self
-antigens and TH17, TH1
and as well as the
antibodies will
enter the joint and
at At this point,
we have release
of proteases and
cytokines, which
will lead directly
to panos formation,
destruction of
bone and cartilage,
and in parallel,
the fibroblasts,
the chondrocytes
and synovial cells
will be activated.
This activation
would lead to further
release of proteases
and cytokines,
further activation
and panus formation,
bone destruction, and
cartilage, and these
cells might also
proliferate, leading
ultimately to the same
output, panus formation,
destruction of
bone, and cartilage.
Rheumatoid arthritis
typically affects
small joints of
hands and feet, at
least initially.
At the histological
level we see pannus,
which is a mass of
edematosynovium,
inflammatory cells,
granulation tissue
and fibroblasts
that grow over
the articular
cartilage and erodes it.
These elements are
very nicely represented
in these two
histological images.
After destruction
of cartilage, the
panus bridges and
the opposing bones
form a fibrous
ankylosis, which may
ossify and result
in bone fusion.
Ultimately, there
is bony ankylosis.
In rheumatoid
arthritis there is
a symmetric joint
involvement.
The joints at the
hand level, except
the distal
interphalangeal joint, the
wrists, the hips,
the knees, cervical
spine, the feet, the
ankles, the elbows
and shoulders are
usually involved
The pain is usually
worse in the morning
The patients
would also present
with systemic
symptoms such as
fever, fatigue
and weight loss
Laboratory investigation
is very important
to confirm the
diagnosis The most
specific and sensitive
test is the anti-CCP.
The patients with
rheumatoid arthritis
present also with
an elevated ESR, an
elevated CRP and a
positive RF titer.
If you examine the
joint fluid, you'll
see that the complement
is decreased.
On this slide, I
thought it's a good idea
to insist on hand
findings in patients with
rheumatoid arthritis.
So, there are Bouchard
nodes in these patients.
These are described
at the proximo
-enterpharyngeal joint.
However, there
are no Heberdine
nodes, but we can see
inflammation in
tendons, ligaments,
sometimes adjacent
skeletal muscle
produces radial
deviation of the wrist,
ulnar deviation
of fingers,
and flexion
hyperextension
fingers, the so
-called swan neck
and boutonniere
deformities.
Rheumatoid arthritis
is also characterized
by a development of
rheumatoid nodules
outside the joints,
for example in the
subcutaneous tissue
of forearm, elbows,
occiput and lumbosacral
area, the areas of
pressure. On evaluation,
these are small,
firm, non-tender,
round to oval masses.
Rheumatoid nodules
are described in
the lungs, and in
this case the patients
are diagnosed with
Kaplan syndrome.
Histological evaluation
of these lesions
will show, as you can
see in this histological
image, necrotizing
granulomas with central
zone of fibrinoid
necrosis surrounded by
prominent ream of
palisading activated
macrophages, many
lymphocytes and plasma cells.
Severe rheumatoid
arthritis may be associated
with acute necrotizing
vasculitis of
small and large arteries
which may involve
the pleura, the
pericardium or the lung.
This in turn will
produce purpura,
cutaneous ulcers and
nile bed infarction.
Ocular changes
in rheumatoid
arthritis are
represented by uveitis,
scleritis and
keratoconjunctivitis.
There is also
interstitial
lung disease in
some patients.
Some other patients
will present
with pericarditis, anemia
of chronic disease.
There is also a Felty
syndrome described
in these patients
which is associated
with neutropenia
and splenomegaly.
This slide summarizes
the most important
differences between
osteoarthritis
and rheumatoid
arthritis. Osteoarthritis
is mechanical slash
degenerative, whereas
rheumatoid arthritis
is autoimmune.
Osteoarthritis is
characterized by
cartilage degeneration
and fragmentation,
bone spurs,
subchondral cysts,
and minimal inflammation.
The rheumatoid arthritis
is associated with
inflammatory panels
which invades and
destroys the cartilage
there is severe chronic
inflammation and ankylosis
so the inflammation
in osteoarthritis
is secondary whereas
in rheumatoid arthritis
is primary osteoarthritis
is worse with
activity whereas the
rheumatoid arthritis
is worse upon waking up
in terms of location
osteoarthritis is
asymmetric initially with
weight-bearing joints
being involved of
course the hands are
involved as well while
the rheumatoid arthritis
is a symmetric
condition which starts
initially in the hands
and feet the laboratory
investigations shows
a non-inflammatory
aspirate in osteoarthritis
whereas rheumatoid
arthritis shows
increased inflammation,
anti-CCP, increased
RF, ESR, CRP
and the decreased
complement.
Osteoarthritis is
characterized by joint
space narrowing,
osteophytes, joint mice,
subchondral sclerosis and
so-called eburonation,
whereas the
rheumatoid arthritis
we have panos formation.
There is no other
extra-articular
feature in
osteoarthritis,
whereas the rheumatoid
arthritis is
associated with
numerous extra-articular
features, such as
rheumatoid nodules,
pleuritis, pericarditis,
Felty syndrome,
as we just described
previously.
Juvenile idiopathic
arthritis represents
a heterogeneous
group of disorders of
unknown cause, which
develops before 16
years of age and lasts
at least six weeks.
The patient presents
with lococytosis,
thrombocytosis,
and anemia.
The patient is seropositive
for antinuclear
antibody, and the ESR
and CRP are increased.
However, the pathogenesis
remains unknown.
There might be some
association with certain
HLA and PT-PN22 gene
variants, but nothing
is well established
at the present time.
They will develop
daily spiking fevers,
a salmon pink macular
rash, and arthritis
is present in at
least two joints.
There is anterior
uveitis, but the patient
does not develop usually
rheumatoid nodules.
The long-term prognosis
is variable, as many
patients may have
other chronic diseases.
However, about
10% will develop
serious functional
disability.
The therapy is
represented by NSAIDs,
steroids, methotrexate,
and TNF inhibitors.
Let's talk now about
defects in hormones
and signal
transduction proteins.
Acrondoplasia,
this is the most
common skeletal dysplasia
and a major cause
of dwarfism.
Thanatodorphic
dysplasia, on the
other hand, is the
most common lethal
form of dwarfism,
and it's seen
in one every 20
,000 life newborns.
This is caused by
if GFR3 gain of
function mutation,
which is different
than those that
cause acrondoplasia.
This patient
presents with
disproportionately
short micromelic limbs,
frontal bossing,
relative microcephaly,
small chest
cavity and bell
-shaped abdomen.
There is an underdeveloped
thoracic cavity
which leads to
respiratory insufficiency
and the patients
frequently die at birth.
At the microscopic
level, the growth
plate shows
reduced chondrocyte
proliferation and
disorganization
within the zone
of proliferation.
Now let's
concentrate a little
bit on achondroplasia
or dwarfism.
This is an autosomal
dominant disorder
characterized by
gain-of-function
mutation in the FGFR
receptor 3 gene.
The FGFR 3 activation
normally inhibits
endochondral growth
which is exaggerated
by FGFR3 gain of
function mutation
the patients present
with ********
cartilage growth,
shortened proximal
extremities, enlarged
head with bulging
forehead, depression
of root of nose despite
trunk of relatively
normal length.
It is not usually
associated
with changes
in longevity,
intelligence or
reproductive status
85% of cases are
sporadic but there
is an increased risk
of achondroplasia
with increased
paternal age.
The inborn activation
of FGFR3 in these
patients leads to a
decreased chondrocyte
activity. There
is also failure
of endochondral
ossification which affects
the longitudinal
bone growth and as
a result the patients
will have short
limbs as you can
see in this drawing.
as we call this event
rhizomelic shortening
the patients
will also have
short metacarpals
short phalanges
and the so-called
trident hand
in trident hand the tips
of fingers cannot touch
there is also a
virus leg deformity
However,
the membrososification
is unaffected. The
skull, facial bones and
clavicle are normal.
The patient will
present with large head
and torso, but there
is frontal bossing,
flattened nasal
bridge and a narrow
foramen magnum.
There is also
spinal lordosis
in these patients.
Osteogenesis imperfecta.
This is a condition
determined by
a defect in
extracellular proteins.
It is in fact the type
1 collagen disease
also known as
brittle bone disease.
It represents the
most common inherited
disorder of
connective tissue,
phenotypically
heterogeneous caused by
deficiencies in type
1 collagen synthesis
mostly affects
bone but also
other tissues with
type 1 collagen
joints eyes ears skin
and teeth it is caused
by mutations in genes
encoding the alpha
1 and alpha 2 chains
of type 1 collagen
mutations result
in misfolding of
collagen polypeptides
and defective
assembly of higher
order collagen chains
mostly autosomal dominant
col1a1 or col1a2.
In conclusion,
the bone is formed but
there is too little bone.
The previously
mentioned mutations are
very important as they
might determine the
fractures which may
be present at birth.
In this condition we
might see mutations
that result in
decreased synthesis
of qualitatively normal
collagen associated
with mild skeletal
abnormalities
or we may see severe
or little phenotypes
associated with
mutant collagens that
interfere with triple
helix formation
type 1 osteogenesis
imperfecta is associated
with normal lifespan
but the patients
experience childhood
fractures that decrease
in frequency following
puberty there is
also a type 2 variant
which is uniformly
fatal in utero or
during perinatal period.
This is associated with
extraordinary
bone fragility and
multiple intrauterine
fractures.
Clinical features.
The patient would
present with multiple
fractures due to
minimal trauma.
These are confused with
some time with
child *****.
The patient develops
hearing loss which
is determined by
both a sensorineural
deficit and an
impaired conduction
as there are several
abnormalities
in the bones of
middle and inner ear.
The eyes present with
blue sclera which
is the ultimate
result of a decreased
collagen content
which makes sclera
translucent with
partial visualization
of the underlying
choroidal veins.
There are also
dental imperfections,
the teeth are small
mishapen and blue
-yellow in color.
All of these
are secondary
to a dentin deficiency.
Osteoporosis. This is
defined as osteopenia
or a decreased bone
mass severe enough
to increase the
risk of fracture.
On X-ray, there is
bone mass at least
2.5 standard
deviations below main
peak bone mass
for a young adult.
The most common
forms of osteoporosis
are senile and
postmenopausal.
In senile osteoporosis,
there is a diminished
ability to make
bone as a result of
reduced proliferative
and biosynthetic
capacity and a reduced
response to growth
factors released by
osteoblasts. Also in
old age there is
decreased physical
activity which leads
to less bone formation.
The first image
represents a section
of a normal
vertebral body with
dense and well
-calcified trabeculate.
On the right side you
see an osteoporotic
vertebra with
ratification of
trabeculate which
weakens the mechanical
properties of the
vertebral body.
Postmenopausal osteoporosis.
After menopause
up to two percent
of cortical bone and
nine percent of
cancellous bone might be
lost per year due to
estrogen deficiency.
Estrogen deficiency
determines
both both formation
and resorption
but resorption dominates.
Estrogen loss is
associated with an
increased secretion
of inflammatory
cytokines release For
example, IL-6, TNF,
and IL-1 by innate
immune cells in
blood and marrow via
unknown mechanisms
This results in increases
and decreases in
rank ligand and OPG,
respectively Which
stimulate osteoclast
recruitment and activity
Histologically
normal bone
is decreased in quantity.
The entire skeleton
is affected,
but certain
bones might be
severely affected
than others.
Postmenopausal
osteoporosis affects
mainly bones or
portions of bones
with increased
surface area, for
example vertebral
bodies. Trabecular
plates become
perforated and thinned,
the interconnections
are loose and this leads
to microfactors and
at the vertebral level
we will have in time
vertebral collapse.
In conclusion, some
genetic factors
associated with
inadequate physical
activity and poor
nutrition may lead to
peak bone mass loss
and osteoporosis.
In menopause,
we have also
decreased serum estrogen,
increased IL-1, IL
-6, and TNF levels.
There is an
increased expression
of rank and
rank ligand and
increased
osteoplast activity.
In aging, we have a
decreased replicative
activity of
osteoprogenitor cells, a
decreased synthetic
activity of osteoblasts
and a decreased
biologic activity
of matrix-bound growth
factors associated
with reduced physical
activity, which
ultimately would
lead to osteoporosis.
There is about 10
million Americans
and 200 million
people worldwide
with osteoporosis
and 1.5 million
osteoportic fracture
occur each year.
The male to female
ratio is 1 to 4.
Men have higher
prevalence of secondary
osteoporosis
about 60%. So the
most common location
for the fractures
is represented by
the vertebral body
followed by the
hip and the wrist.
The A vertebral
body fracture is a
compression
fracture, especially
in the thoracic
and lumbar region.
It is painful and when
multiple can cause
significant loss of
height and deformities,
lumbar lordosis
and kyphoscoliosis.
There is also a very
important fracture,
the femoral neck
fracture, which
leads to loss of
mobility and high
mortality, especially
in the elderly with
other chronic
conditions associated.
Also very serious is the
distal radius fracture,
which in elderly
patients can heal
with a great deal
of difficulty.
This radiological image
shows the anterior
posterior radiograph
of the proximal part
of femur of a patient
who had osteoporosis,
showing a fracture
of the femoral neck.
Osteoporosis is
detected in plain X-rays
when 30 to 40% of
bone mass is lost.
Usually the diagnosis
is done by a
DIXA scan. DIXA is
the abbreviation
for Dual Energy X
-ray Absorciometry
and is recommended
for all
women more than
65 years of age.
This test provides
a T-score which
basically compares
the bone density of
the patient to a
healthy 30-year-old.
A score of less
or equal with
minus 2.5 indicates
osteoporosis.
A score between minus
2.5 and minus 1 is
diagnostic for osteopenia,
while a score of
at least minus 1
suggests a healthy bone.
These patients should
be prescribed diet
-reaching calcium and
vitamin D supplements,
weight-bearing
exercises, and
bifosphonates, which
are known to reduce
osteoclast activity
and bone resorption
Osteopetrosis
represents a group of
rare genetic diseases
characterized by
reduced bone resorption
due to deficient
osteoclast development
or function
This ultimately
results in diffuse
symmetrical
skeletal sclerosis.
I would like to
highlight that the
term osteopetrosis
would imply
something hard,
stone-like. However,
bones in these
patients are
brittle and
fracture easily.
Osteopetrosis represents
several variants
based on mode of
inheritance as well as
severity of clinical
findings most mutations in
osteopetrosis interfere
with acidification
of the osteoclast
resorption pit which
is needed for the
solution of calcium
hydroxyapatite within
the bone matrix
these patients
present in fact with
a mutation in
carbonic anhydrase 2
which is associated
with inability to
generate acidic
environment necessary for
osteoclast function. The
osteoclasts are defective,
they cannot resolve
bone properly and
this leads to dense but
fracture prone bones.
Ultimately the
bone fills marrow
space leading to
pancytopenia and
extra medullary
hematopoiesis.
Radiology in this
patient would reveal a
symmetric sclerosis, the
so-called bone in bone
pattern. This is
determined by a bone which
is not remodeled but
tends to be woven
rather than lamellar.
The long bones have no
medullary cavity
because the osteoclast
activity is deficient and
they will present with
the so-called Ehlenmeyer
flask deformity.
Also in this patient
we might see a
narrow neural
foraminum and various
types of cranial
nerve compressions
associated with
pulses and deafness.
There is an increased
risk of fractures
especially in the lower
extremity followed
by upper extremity
and axial skeleton.
A severe infantile
osteopetrosis is usually
autosomal recessive
transmitted and is
evident in utero or
soon after birth. The
autosomal dominant
forms are milder and
might not be detected
until adolescence.
Therapy is with bone
marrow transplant and
is potentially curative
as by this procedure
we provide the patient
with hematopoietic
precursors for the
functional osteoclasts.
Malasia and rickets
represent metabolic
entities determined by
defective mineralization
of osteoid or cartilaginous
growth plates.
They are
associated with a
low vitamin D,
low sunlight
and kidney disease.
Osteomalasia is seen in
adults with defective
mineralization of
osteoid, while rickets
is diagnosed in
children with effective
mineralization of
cartilaginous growth plates.
The incidence is 1
in 1000 in the US.
It is therefore fairly
low and is due to a
dairy product fortification
with vitamin D
and adequate sunlight
in most of the people.
The laboratory studies
will show a decreased
vitamin D, decreased
calcium absorption,
increased PTH and
decreased phosphates.
The osteobloids are
hyperactive and there
is an increase in
alkaline phosphatase.
The therapy is represented
by administration
of large doses of
vitamin D, more
than 1,000 international
units per day.
Osteomalacia is
associated with loser
zone which is an
insufficiency fracture
seen at the axillary
border of the
scapula, the rib
or posterior ulna.
In rickets there is
epiphyseal widening
and metaphyseal
cupping or fraying. The
patients present with
genuvarum or bow legs
and rachytic rosary
which represents osteoid
deposition at the
costochondral junction.
Patriot's disease.
Patriot's disease
is associated
with increase by disorder
structurally and
sound bone mass.
There are three
sequential phases.
An initial osteolytic
stage which is
followed by a mixed
osteoclastic-osteoblastic
stage and ultimately
by a burnout
quiescent osteoskeleotic
stage in which
the osteoblast
activity predominates.
Oftentimes it
presents in late
adulthood and
becomes progressively
more common with
increasing age.
It is relatively
common in Caucasians in
England, France, Austria,
regions of Germany,
Australia, New Zealand
and US. It is very
rare in Scandinavia,
China, Japan and Africa.
The exact incident
is not known
because of many
asymptomatic patients.
About 1% of the
US population
more than 40
years of age is
thought to have
a Pages disease.
The major cause of
Page's disease is
unknown. However, there
is evidence of both
genetic and environmental
contributions.
Approximately 50%
of familiar Page's
disease and 10% of
sporadic cases are
associated with
mutations in the SQSTM1
gene, which increases
the NFKB activity,
enhancing osteoclast
activity as well.
Some studies suggest
chronic infection
of osteoclast
precursors by measles or
other RNA viruses as
major contributors.
As mentioned, there are
three pathogenic stages.
The osteolytic stage
is characterized by
increased osteoclastic
activity and bone
resorption. This is
followed by a mixed
stage in which there
is an increase in
both the activity
of osteoclast and
osteoblasts. During this
stage we see resorption
and compensatory
bone reformation.
The osteosclerotic or
the burnout phase is
characterized by
increased number and
activity of osteoblasts
with bone formation.
Sometime all three phases
might coexist
in a given bone.
Histology varies over
time and across sites,
however the hallmark of
Page's disease
is represented
by a jigsaw puzzle
-like appearance
produced by
unusually prominent
cement lines which
join haphazardly
oriented units
of lameral bone
as you can see in this
microscopic image.
this is the mosaic
pattern of lameral bone
characteristic for
the sclerotic phase
histology is
less specific
during other
phases of disease
osteoclasts in
this setting may
be abnormally large with
increased nuclei
up to 100 nuclei
they persist in
mixed phase but many
bone surfaces
also aligned by
plump osteoblasts
in the mixed phase.
Marrow adjacent to
bone forming surface is
replaced by loose
connective tissue containing
osteoprogenitor cells
and blood vessels.
The end result is
represented by coarsely
thickened trabecular
and soft and porous
cortices which lack
structural stability
and make bone
vulnerable to fractures.
One of the most
important radiological
signs in Page's disease
is represented by
skull thickening,
associated with auditory
forearm narrowing
and hearing loss.
Bone thickening is
also seen at the
level of vertebral
bodies, the so
-called picture
-framed vertebrae.
Clinical features
are extremely
variable and depend
on the extent and site
of disease. We
describe a monostotic
form of disease
in about 50% of
cases and polyostotic
in the reminder
Axial skeleton
or proximal femur
are involved in
up to 80% of cases
However, most cases are
asymptomatic and
are discovered as
incidental
radiographic finding
Sometimes the patient
would complain of pain
which is localized
to the affected bone
due to micro fractures
or bone overgrowth that
compresses spinal and
cranial nerve roots
There is ***********
of craniofacial
skeleton which might
produce in severe
cases leontiasis
osea or lion face
and a cranium so
heavy that it is
difficult for a
person to hold head up
Weight bearing
causes anterior
bowing of the
femur and tibia and
distorts femoral
heads resulting in
severe secondary
osteoarthritis
Choke stick type fractures
are common usually
involve long bones
of lower extremities
There is vertebral
compression
fractures that
can result in
spinal cord injury
and kyphosis
Some patients will
present with high
output heart failure,
which results
after creation of
arteriovenous shunts
In rare cases,
hypervascularity of
a pajatic bone
warms overlying skin
and if the disease is
poliostotic, there is
a significant increased
blood flow at the
skin level which can
act as an arteriovenous
shunt leading to high
output heart failure.
Also very rarely
in less than
1% of individuals
with Page's
disease a sarcoma
could develop.
However laboratory
studies will show an
increased alkaline
phosphatase which
is a marker for
increased bone formation
but the calcium
phosphoryl and PTH are
normal. Usually
Page's disease is not
serious or life
-threatening Most patients
have mild symptoms
suppressed by therapy
with calcitonin
and bisphosphonates
Osteonecrosis or
avascular necrosis It is
mainly determined
by fractures and
corticosteroid administration
The most common
location is represented
by femoral head due to
medial circumflex
femoral artery injury.
In 80% of cases, there is
bilateral hip
involvement.
In addition,
other predisposing
conditions are
alcohol *****,
Biphosphonate therapy,
connective tissue
disease, trauma,
chronic pancreatitis,
Gaucher disease,
pregnancy,
radiation therapy,
sickle cell
crisis, tumors,
and decompression
sickness There are two
types of infarcts in
avascular necrosis,
medullary infarcts and
subchondral infarcts
Medullary infarcts
are geographic
in shape and
involve both the
trabecular bone
and the marrow
The subchondral
infarcts are
triangular or
wedge-shaped and
involve the
subchondral plate
as a base where the
necrosis starts.
Overlying articular
cartilage remain viable
due to nutrients within
the synovial fluid.
Microscopy reveals
empty lacunates
surrounded by
necrotic adipocytes.
The symptoms
depend on location
and extent of the
infarct. Usually,
subchondral
infarcts cause pain
initially associated
with activity.
However, the pain
becomes constant and is
associated with decreased
range of motion.
Subchondral infarcts
often collapse,
resulting in secondary
osteoarthritis.